[Music]
Kim jong-un is betrayed as a God in
North Korea and a lunatic tyrant abroad
the supreme leader has tangled with the
world's most powerful men including the
President of the United States Donald
Trump who called Kim a madman with
nuclear weapons this is how a young man
his late Clinton's became the supreme
leader of one of America's most feared
nations the Kim dynasty began in 1948
when Kim's grandfather Kim il-sung
founded the Democratic People's Republic
of Korea the great leader ruled for
forty-five years before he died of a
heart attack he was succeeded by his son
the dear leader Kim jong-il until his
death in 2011 also from a heart attack
then the third Kim Kim jong-un took the
top job no one is sure when the latest
Kim the supreme leader was born all
where other than it was either in 1983
or 1984 he is the son of one of several
women to have had relations with his
father Kim jong-il before his ascension
Kim was barely seen in public and his
upbringing is shrouded in secrecy he's
widely thought to have been educated at
a private school in Switzerland no one
remembers him the little we do know
about his childhood is according to his
personal sushi chef Kenji Fujimoto
according to Kenji Fujimoto as Kim
jong-un grow into adulthood he loves
smoking even saint-laurent cigarettes
enjoyed drinking
Johnnie Walker whiskey had had his own
mercedes-benz 600 which is a very
expensive luxury sedan when his father
Kim Jong Il's started having health
problems a propaganda campaign kicked
into gear to thrust his spoiled son into
the spotlight
[Music]
[Music]
when his father died Kim quickly took
hold of power solidifying his control
through a mixture of charm and brutality
he broke with the reclusive style of his
father by unveiling his wife Lee sold
you and making numerous public speeches
[Music]
he has also used his love of basketball
to engage in diplomatic theatrics
inviting former NBA star Dennis Rodman
back to Pyongyang for what is believed
to be his fifth time according to the PO
mats in North Korea
you know Kim jong-un likes to drink
likes to party all night and Dennis
Rodman one of the frequent visitors it
has talked about that he reportedly
recruited many young female companions
for his silent
entertainment troop on the flip side
Kim has used fear and control to keep
rivals in check executing senior members
of the military including several of his
defense ministers and his uncle a South
Korean report says Kim personally
ordered the execution of 340 people in
his first six years in charge but it's
his single-minded pursuit of nuclear
weapons which has put the international
community on edge a host of sanctions
from China and the US have done little
to stop or even slow kim's ambitions I
think the perception is that or at least
with kim jong hoon is that he feels that
having a nuclear weapon will give them
greater leverage in any talks between
the u.s. and where the kim is capable of
an effective nuclear strike is open to
question but his aggressive rhetoric and
regular missile tests are troubling the
international community doesn't help
that the president is cause of a madman
and the senator calls him a crazy fat
kid these images actually really belie I
think a pretty astute leader whether
he's a dictator or not he has been able
to
maintain control absolute control over
the country madman or stupa litical
operator either way kim jong un's
political ambitions are putting his
regime on a collision course with the US
as well as his neighbors with a standing
army of 1.3 million and 7.6 million more
in reserve North Korea is on a permanent
war footing and ready to roll across its
border into South Korea
you